[Music]
hi everyone thank you for joining the
Google for games developer summit my
name is Moe I am a cloud gaming
architect at Google cloud today I will
be joined by Christina and Jason
community to talk about unity game
simulation if you're a game developer
you probably know unity deleting
real-time 3d development engine that
supports over 25 platforms and powers
50% of all new games
what you might not know is UD and Google
cloud have pointed for years to make
game development easier and more
accessible for more creators using the
power to cloud last fall UD announced
unity simulation a new cloud-based
product that enables designers
developers and creators to generate
synthetic trading data at scale as well
as test train and validate or their
computer vision and perception projects
in unity by harnessing the power of the
cloud within Google Cloud uni leverages
Google's turnkey kubernetes solution gke
gke or google kubernetes arjun gives you
need developers a secure way to manage
and operate simulations at scale gke
provides strong security defaults such
as encryption at rest encryption and
transit leading to a more secure
environment for uni developers as an
added benefit of learning gke uni is
able to seamlessly integrate or kiseop
ease ecosystem unity uses Google's
virtual private cloud to define its
global network as well as Google cloud
identity and access management to manage
fine-grained access control each of
which have first-class integrations
within gke today we're excited to help
our friends at unity announced their
latest innovative product in the world
of simulation that's specifically
tailored for game developers I would
like to introduce Christina from unity
to talk about unity game simulation
thanks mo creating games is hard in
launching the quality game is even
harder yeah the first impression your
game makes on your players can determine
its long-term success to build a quality
game you need to thoroughly balance it
prior to launch a well balanced game
will create a fun experience for all
your players you'll appeal to more
players and keep them happy and engaged
which means a higher lifetime value so
how do you create a well balanced game
currently the answer is extensive manual
balancing through spreadsheets and human
play testers you'll tediously try to
find the right damage value for a weapon
or the ideal speed of a character but
these are just two of hundreds of
possible parameters that you might want
to adjust in your game in order to get
these right you may need to spend hours
tweaking values and oversimplified and
inaccurate spreadsheets or you contract
dozens of human play testers but the
feedback you receive is subjective and
costly today were excited to announce
unity game simulation supported by the
Google cloud infrastructure unity game
simulation is an affordable solution
that complements your pre-launch play
test to provide faster iteration and
results at scale the tool allows you to
balance more and iterate on your game
more often using the online dashboard
you have the power to set up run and
analyze thousands of simulations because
these player interactions run
simultaneously you also speed up your
balancing the scale of cloud balancing
provides more accurate results than
manual balancing and spreadsheets can't
replicate this quantitative balancing
coverage costs a fraction of a
playtesters hourly rate giving them more
time to focus on the look and feel of
the game let's dive into an example
theory on games a Canadian game
development studio created death
carnival a fast paced top-down shooter
one of the features of the game is the
and socket system each weapon allows
players to select a base weapon ammo
weapon module and temporary power-ups
each of these combinations is made up of
many variables that control the
playstyle and efficiency of the weapon
in earlier versions of the game the team
balanced weapons by hand they would
configure a weapon compile a build send
it out to play testers and watch them
play based on the feedback they would
reconfigure the weapons and repeat each
iteration of this process would take
hours
enter unity game simulation theory on
used the tool to run thousands of
simulations they were able to identify
the right combinations of base weapons
ammo weapon modules and power-ups for
their desired survivability and level
completion time this allowed them to
ensure the weapons were balanced by
configuring the weapon weapon parameters
and multistage simulations Farion was
able to condense the equal equivalent of
a hundred and sixty five million play
throughs into just ten efficient
simulations taking just over three days
to balance their weapon system they
estimate that the tool saved them
$80,000 and six hundred hours of dev
time those resources would just
previously have been spent on managing
play testers measuring weapon
performance and compiling builds now
they can instead be spent on polishing
the creative elements of the game Jason
an engineer on the team will now
demonstrate how Furion achieved these
results after deciding to use game
simulation a game developer at Furion
implements the Unity game simulation
package and uploads a bill to the game
simulation service from the editor
window I won't go through this in detail
but the process is simple once the
developers uploaded the death Carnival
simulation build it's time to create a
simulation from the web UI this is where
designers configure and run simulations
for this death carnival simulation we
will be testing 45 key combinations of
weapons ammo and modules a hundred times
each in order to establish the mean
performance of each combination with
high confidence
let's name this build phase one and
we'll select our build from the
drop-down for the values in our
simulation will be testing shotgun
machine gun and missile our ammo count
will be 10 15 20 25 and 30
and if our weapon module will be using
triple shot wave and burst once the
simulation is finished we'll get a
spreadsheet with a row for each
combination of these parameter values
and lastly we'll run each semi each
combination a hundred times so in total
this will run 4,500 combinations of
simulations so fast forward one hour and
we can see that this simulation has
already completed and we have our
aggregate data so let's open up this
data I've gone ahead and imported that
file into Google sheets and made a chart
with the level completion time by weapon
combination so here we can see the chart
and in this chart we see the shotgun a
machine gun both have a some pretty
underpowered combinations as a next step
I can buff these combinations and run
this simulation once more
Furion has already done this so let's
take a look at the final results and we
can see that the underpowered
combinations have come down pretty
drastically in player completion time
which translates to a much better
gameplay experience for death carnivals
players now that we've seen unity game
simulation in action let's peel back the
onion a bit and talk about the
underlying infrastructure we chose gke
to build unity game simulation on top of
because it gives us the container
management we wanted with Google compute
engine we would have needed to manage
the components individually such as auto
scaling networking security container
health etc with Dae we just specify what
we want and is managed for us one of the
most important features in building
unity game simulation is GK ease auto
scaling we need the ability to
dynamically
scale up our number of resources so we
can quickly handle workloads of
thousands of simulations without having
to pay for idle resources because games
all have different system requirements
using separate node pools were able to
adjust this instance type for each game
when we schedule a simulation with Unity
game simulation users tend to run a mix
of smaller and larger batches of
simulations so it's important for us to
have fast scaling of resources the
smaller number of simulations a user is
running the more impactful any extra
overhead is so being able to quickly
scale up as needed it lets us handle
both types of workloads in addition to
gke we use the number of other GCP
offerings in building this tool one
example is stack driver which we use for
our services the log aggregation and
metric instrumentation around gke
and other Google cloud resources help
minimize the work in setting up our
dashboards and alerting as we transition
from our initial proof-of-concept into a
production system because we're running
user code it's also important for us to
sandbox everything as much as possible
with iam and rbac
the user code containers can be
configured to run with no permissions to
any gke or GCP resources even on the
same node I am also helps secure our
resources and data by locking them down
to just a few necessary admins for our
services so we're able to create a
service account for each of them with
the minimum required permissions in
addition to gke and other products we
just mentioned I'd like to quickly cover
some of the other tools that we found
very useful in the development of Unity
game simulation first is cloud sequel
which we're using as the database for
our services that manage our job stay in
orchestration second is GCR which we're
using along with I am that I mentioned
earlier for securely managing all of our
docker containers we also use data proc
for handling the aggregation of our
simulation data from each of the
individual simulation instances and
finally terraform which helps us manage
all the GCP infrastructure that we have
in summary unity game simulation creates
a more efficient accurate and affordable
solution for game balancing it
complements play testing backing human
feedback with quantitate
of data try to open beta for free visit
unity dot-com / products / of game -
simulation for more information and
thank you all for watching
[Music]